on a vu des tourbillons commencer à
monter d'une intensité une puissance une
extrême puissance vraiment sur une
courte durée on a juste eu le temps de
se mettre à l'abri dans les maisons et
puis enfin c'était vraiment intense
ça a duré 15 30 secondes quoi une
centaine de maisons qui sont concernées
par des dégâts qui sont extrêmement
importants ça va de la maison totalement
détruite à certaines qui ont des
toitures complètement arrachées d'autres
ce sont des plantes murs ou des
véhicules retournés et du mobilier aussi
totalement détruit c'est 200 habitants
sur une population totale de 370 qui
sont impactés par cet ordre